if your brain is a record of the past
and you are living by the same emotions
that have defined you
for the last 10 years
and you keep thinking the same thoughts
that make the same chemicals and those
same chemicals drive the same thoughts
then your body
as the unconscious mind
does not know the difference between an
actual experience in your life that
creates an emotion
and an emotion that you're creating by
thought alone
and so your body is believing it's in
the same past experience
24 hours a day seven days a week
365 days a year and your body is
programmed into the past
and you can create a new future holding
on to the emotions of the past
how many people understand what i'm
talking about
so then
when you react
to someone or something in your life
you have a choice
that when an event changes how you feel
there's a chemical change that's taking
place in your body
and most people don't think they can
control their emotional reactions
and so then when you react to some
co-worker
or some relative
or somebody in traffic
the moment you react emotionally you are
altered chemically
and if you don't know how to control
your emotional reaction after that event
and you allow those emotions to linger
for hours or days
you know what that's called
called a mood
what's wrong with you
oh i'm in a mood
really
why are you in a mood well this thing
happened to me four days ago
and i'm having one long emotional
reaction
and if you keep that same refractory
period going on for weeks or months
that's called a temperament
hey
why is she so angry i don't know why are
you so angry why are you so bitter
why are you so enchilada
[Music]
because i had this experience
seven months ago
and i
memorizing my emotional reaction
and if you keep that same refractory
period going on for years on end
that's called a personality trait
and people wear their emotions on their
sleeve
and that's who they think they are
and they will talk about the past to
validate why they're not creating the
life that they want
so then if you wake up in the morning
mexico city
and you are not being defined by a
vision that's bigger than you
and it doesn't get you out of bed and
inspire you into possibility
and you get up
living from the old hardware of the past
and the old emotions stored in your body
do you know what's going to happen to
you
you're going to wake up and you're going
to open your eyes
and you're going to see the same people
and go to the same places and do the
exact same thing at the exact same time
and the moment you open your eyes
all of a sudden now it's your external
environment that's controlling how you
think and feel
because you have a neurological network
in your brain for every person you know
every place that you go everything that
you own everything that you do
and the moment you open your eyes and
you see the same people and go to the
same places and do the exact same thing
at the exact same time it's your
external environment that's turning on
different circuits in your brain
causing you to think equal to everything
that you know
and you told me you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny
and as long as your thinking equal to
your environment
you keep creating the same life
to change
to truly change is to think greater than
your environment
to think greater than the circumstances
in your life to think greater than the
conditions in your world and every great
person in history knew this
whether it was mahatma gandhi martin
luther king the wright brothers joan of
arc
they all had a vision
need motivation watch top 10 with
believe nation hey it's evan carmichael
and i make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
dr joe dispenza and my take on his top
10 rules to success
enjoy
rule number two carry positive energy i
always say to people
when was the last time you sat with your
heart and just worked with it like so
that it's not contracted and afraid and
protected
it takes practice to to do that and and
so we we work with people in letting
them
we give them numerous opportunities
to practice this over and over and over
again and sooner or later pedal by pedal
it starts to bloom and all of a sudden
there's an authentic smile on their face
and once energy meets the heart it goes
right to the brain we have
we did this study where we hooked up an
electrocardiogram to an
electroencephalogram an
electroencephalogram is a brain mapping
machine so we measure 19 or 26 different
compartments and we're looking to see
all different kind of activity in the
brain
but we measured the heart along with it
and when the heart starts beating
coherently
in a sense of order
like like taking a big sheet j and going
like that the heart sends a wave right
up to the brain
and the brain goes into these beautiful
states of alpha the heart is telling the
brain it's safe to create again it's
safe to imagine it's safe to dream of a
new future
and
there's the stroke volume of the heart
in order and then you see these two or
three seconds of beautiful coherent
alpha the brain is in it's it's in that
creative state then there's a pause and
it happens again and yeah it's it's it's
beauty it's a it's a symphony if you
don't have that mechanism you can have
all the intention in the world
but there's no carrier wave i mean
and people when they make energy reach
their heart there's an external field
that's created it's it's it's magnetic
it's it's it's measurable
and that energy
is frequency and if that frequency is
coherent it can carry the intent
or thought on a coherent brain of that
future the energy of suffering
cannot carry the thought of health or
wealth it's not consistent with it it
carries a different set of thoughts
so then
the training then
is getting people into those hard states
because
once they start trading that fear or
that pain or that frustration or trying
or whatever forcing you know control
for gratitude and they just let all that
go and i say to them listen
if you can't feel gratitude if you can't
feel love i just want to know what
you've been practicing feeling every day
because that feeling that you're
practicing is what you're always feeling
now let's practice feeling something
else in the beginning it's not going to
be easy but you got to keep following
the formula keep doing it keep doing it
keep doing it
well
when they start feeling gratitude it's
very interesting because
the emotional signature of gratitude
is that something wonderful just
happened to you
something favorable is happening to you
right so
you've just received something or you're
receiving something you say thank you so
gratitude
is the ultimate state of receiving
emotionally
so when you move into a state of
gratitude and you open your heart you
will accept believe and surrender to the
thoughts equal to that emotional state
and you'll program your autonomic
nervous system into a different destiny
you could say i'm healthy i'm healthy
i'm healthy i'm wealthy and wealthy and
wealthy and wealthy and free and free
i'm free and your body is conditioned in
the misery and it's saying
no you're not and that thought stops
right at the brain stem
it never makes it to the body because
the body is on a different program
so then
while the person starts trading that and
they start opening their heart well
their immune system gets stronger by 50
percent 50 in three days they start
making immunoglobulins their body's
natural defense against viruses and
bacteria 50
not a little bit
a lot that's that's one study and so
trading that telling the body it's in
the in the environment where it already
happened
and so that's when the miracles start
happening that's when people say
i'm not doing anything well of course
you're not you don't have to rule number
three feel invincible what are a few
things we can do to support our inner
environment on a daily basis ah
well listen um the first thing and the
most important thing for me is knowledge
and information
knowledge is really power and and
knowledge and information about yourself
shouldn't it should empower you it
should empower the self right so when we
learn about the immune system and all
that can do and when you say oh my god
you mean not every virus
gets to me in fact no and the more you
the more you understand that and the
more you coax your immune system into
love and into
like we i just did this little thing on
um on our social media where i was
talking about the inner army of order
and what would be the signal you would
want that inner army to get and so we
created this meditation and we said what
would invincibility feel like signal
your body and feel invincible
how would you feel if you had an
uncompromising will
that you had more energy than you could
possibly imagine show your body what it
feels like
because it is that emotion of
invincibility that emotion of an
uncompromising goal to empower your
inner world and you have the intent of
that's what it's for
wow get ready because you're going to
start creating a cadence and a rhythm
where your your body's going whoa what
what are the what is all these new
chemicals what are all these new signals
right hey it's time hey hey uh now all
of a sudden receptor sites on the t
cells go wow we got some new signals
coming from the boss here let's open up
all those t-cell receptors let's go we
in fact we're we're we would love a
little fight right now because we got a
lot of time on our hands and we got all
our receptors turned on
oh i mean that that would be
a signal for your body we also know that
if you could just trade fear
and frustration and
resentment and
suffering
for an elevated emotion and truly open
your heart again and practice doing that
you'll heal you'll heal you'll heal
because i mean all healings happen in
the heart rule number four be
intentional can you believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet
but you've thought about enough times in
your mind that your brain is literally
changed to look like the event has
already occurred
the latest research in neuroscience
says you can change your brain from
living in the past to living in the
future
and can you fall in love with that
vision
to such a degree
that you come out of your resting state
and change guilt or suffering into
inspiration and joy and gratitude
to such a degree that your body as the
unconscious mind
does not know the difference between
that external event and what you're
creating internally
so that your body believes it's living
in that future in the present moment and
you begin to signal new genes
in new ways
to change your body
to look like the event has already
occurred
the latest research in epigenetics says
you can change your body by thought
alone
now reason this with me
if there's physical evidence
in your brain and body
to look like the event has already
occurred
your brain and body are no longer living
in the past they're living in the future
and you will walk right into your vision
most people in this audience all of you
have done something great in your life
you all have
no reason this
you woke up one day or you had a wild
thought out of nowhere
and that thought
was a possibility in the future
something new you wanted to experience
and the moment you started thinking
about this experience
the moment you started contemplating
this potential reality
you turned on a part of your brain
called the frontal lobe
the crowning achievement of the human
being
it's 40
of your entire brain
it is the creative center
and it has connections to all other
parts of the brain
and the moment you said what would it be
like to be a leader
what would it be like to be successful
what would it be like to have this
vision come true
the moment you asked that open-ended
question
you turned on this part of the brain
because the rest of the brain is just a
bunch of automatic programs
and now the frontal lobe the creative
center wakes up
and it has connections to the entire
brain it's the ceo it's the boss it's
the symphony leader of the brain and the
moment you get creative the frontal lobe
begins to select different networks of
neurons that are stored in your brain
from things you've learned or
experienced
and as you begin to think a what-if
question it begins to select these
different networks and begins to
seamlessly piece them together
and making your brain fire in new
sequences and in new patterns and new
combinations
and whenever you make your brain work
differently you're changing your mind
because mind is the brain in action
mind is the brain at work
and the moment those neurons fire in
tandem
you get a picture in your mind
a hologram
a vision
an abstraction
and for those people who are passionate
that thought that their thinking
begins to create an elevated emotion
they become inspired
they feel enthusiastic in theos filled
with god
they become passionate
they started to open their hearts
and all of a sudden they're combining a
clear intention with an elevated emotion
and it's the combination of a clear
intention and an elevated emotion in our
research over and over again
that proves then the person now is
changing fundamentally
changing biologically
changing internally
and their brain and body are moving from
living in the past into living in the
future
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five look for truth we
have such compelling evidence in science
with brain scans you make your brain
work better you can make your heart work
better you make your immune system work
better you can make your cells go from
really sick to really healthy we've got
great evidence you can become immune to
serious viruses you can be immune to
bacteria we've got the measurements you
can blame in your life
we have great evidence and the people
aren't monks they're not they're not
nuns they're not religious scholars
they're just common people
and then we have testimony
of people who are the example of truth
they are they are the example of truth i
would rather have dinner with those
people than anybody anybody out there
they know something right
so evidence then becomes the loudest
voice right and and that's what i think
what people are looking for right now
the truth is so lost in sensationalism
and the truth is so lost
in emotional agreement
and so people who want to feel fear
they program themselves and accept
believe and surrender that people who
want to be hate be hateful
it's all there it's all there and it's a
it's a matrix to find the way out right
and
and i think i think there's a door i
just i just think that we have to
trust the innate information that that
comes from within us rule number six see
the greater good people that were
traumatized
from childhood that were abused sexually
physically emotionally that were
suicidal that all kinds of health
conditions they came to the edge
of that emotion that kept them connected
to the past and they were ready to give
up in one meditation because
they they never had felt an emotion like
this that they could remember that it
was so intense
and they thought about all the times for
the last year that they never missed a
day of doing a meditation even when they
didn't feel like it or they wanted to
quit halfway through and they didn't
they went all the way they thought about
all those times
that they went to that point and they
went one more time really and their
words are always the same
and my heart
blew wide open
and i look back at my entire past and i
don't want to change one thing in my
past because it brought me to this
present moment and i can see my
betrayers
i could
see the people in my life
that had a hand in this and i have
nothing but compassion for them because
now the person is no longer viewing that
path from the same level of
consciousness they're viewing it from a
place of love of wholeness and they see
the greater good of all of it and now
their their
their their conditions their health
conditions their endometriosis their
uterine tumors i mean whatever it is
literally
goes disappears and they have an
incredible incredible change in their
brain chemistry they're in love with
life they're off their meds they're not
suicidal they're why would they be
they're free
so it can happen in an instant when the
heart is healed and everybody gets the
new signal the body's out of the past
the body's no longer feeling the
emotions of the past and sometimes
we got to come right up against that
edge that's yeah that's the great moment
rule number seven understand the immune
system our immune system is kind of like
our rudimentary nervous system
it has cells that are mobile and they're
called plasma cells or white blood cells
and their job is an internal defense in
many of our bodies plasma cells
line the mucous membranes gut the
digestive tract
all the orifices of the body the nose
the mouth ears
and it's a line of defense
against foreign invaders and toxins and
when the immune system is
facing
uh some foreign invader whether it be a
virus
a bacteria a mold a fungus
some foreign agent
it is the army of plasma cells that move
towards the danger
and begin to
attack these foreign agents
and
there are cells in your immune system
called t cells
and t cells are like the ninjas of the
immune system
they release
very powerful chemicals that can
denature and break down any foreign
invader
and t cells have these little trumpets
that stick out on the receptor site so
picture this big circular spherical glob
and you have all these different
receptors and these t cell receptors are
these long trumpet
appendages
and when they come up to a virus or they
come up to
a bacteria when they come up to even a
cancer cell
they notice that it's a foreign agent
and immediately this t cell receptor
attaches to that foreign agent and
begins to release a lot of unhealthy
chemicals that begin to cause that
foreign agent to die and then memorizes
that foreign agent and passes the
information on to the army of the rest
of the white blood cells in the body and
and this is a strong immune system and
when plasma cells and white blood cells
begin to function well they release
chemicals called immunoglobulins
and immunoglobulins are proteins that
are in the shape of a y
and those y shaped proteins are
antibodies and what they do is when the
the white blood cell releases an
antibody
it begins to block the receptors
of the foreign agent that's trying to
attack
the white blood cells so when a healthy
immunoglobulin is
released
it suppresses uh the
the warfare uh the the cell receptors
that are trying to attack the white
blood cell and now you have a strong
defense you have a strong immune system
and yeah your body right now is doing
that in fact your body is always
evaluating all those foreign agents
whether it's a virus a bacteria or even
a cancer cell
and it's working to keep the body in
balancing the immune system a strong
healthy immune system does that
constantly always behind the scenes of
your awareness rule number eight step
into the unknown if you give people
sound information
and then they can repeat that
information
they're wiring it in their brain
they're creating a new model of
understanding
if you show them how to apply that
information
if they do it properly they will have
some type of transformation
that transformation
isn't something that causes people to
feel bad or unworthy it causes them to
open their hearts
it causes them to feel joy to feel
gratitude they feel differently
and if you're able to then
create that elevated emotion
and you teach people more information
they will continue to transform
themselves and that's called evolution
if you think the same thoughts the same
thoughts always lead to the same choices
the same choices lead to the same
behaviors the same behaviors create the
same experiences and the same
experiences produce the same feelings
and you're now caught in your old self
but
new thoughts
should lead to new choices
and new choices should lead to new
behaviors new behaviors should create
new experiences and new experiences
should create new emotions and that
should inspire evolution
we say that your personality
creates your personal reality
and your personality is made up of how
you think
how you act and how you feel we could
say that your personality is your state
of being
so now geniuses
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
keep demonstrating the same behaviors
keep living by the same feelings and
emotions
your personal reality is going to stay
exactly the same
but
if you have new thoughts
that lead to new choices that
demonstrate new actions that create new
experiences that cause you to feel
differently you will begin to walk into
a new future how many people understand
this
so most people try to create a new
personal reality as the same personality
and it doesn't work
you literally have to become someone
else so
crossing the river of change going from
the old self to the new self requires
you stepping into the unknown
and if you are now in the unknown and
you feel uncomfortable because you're
leaving guilt behind
[Music]
you leave unworthiness behind you see
the biggest problem with most people
is they want to create wealth but they
feel lack
they want a new life but they feel
unworthy
that's mind and body in opposition
and our research shows that you can
teach people how to recondition their
body to a new mind and when that occurs
they begin to create very powerful
things in their life rule number nine
figure out your life's purpose what do
you believe is the purpose of life
overall
to figure out the purpose of life
okay i know i mean i mean i i really
think it's i think the mathematics
uh that i've looked at says
there's infinite experiences to have you
will never know the end
so then if you study any religion i i
mean i've looked at a lot of them it's
this concept of eternity that the soul
is going to be around for eternity
that's a long time
and that means you got to be okay with
you
for a very long time yeah so
i think it's i think it's the creation
of more experiences and i think
to to
i think we came from source from
singularity from oneness
and we have descended down into density
a fooled by our senses into separation
and every
single being has a spark of oneness of
the divine within them and we got so
separate
that we now have our own free will to
answer the question is there more
because if your oneness it gets kind of
boring after a while like is there
anything else well the moment you ask if
there's anything else you're no longer
oneness you're something other than
oneness right and you're a a different
consciousness separate from oneness
so i think then we live life and then
when we can predict the feeling of
everything that can happen in our life
and gets boring and
we're not impressed by anyone or
anything we ask the same question
is there more and that's when the soul
goes
all right well it's been how many
lifetimes you've been doing this okay
there's an awakening and the and we ask
that question and then all of a sudden
we start getting information and books
and stuff and meet people and it gets
exciting and
and it's the it's it's how the universe
works and so we climb out of this
and i just think there's so many
incredible experiences that are left in
the unknown uh that we get to have and
and then of course when
the journey is over and you evolve to
that point
uh then you take that wisdom and you say
here's what i learned and it was scary
down there boy i tell a great story and
then you hang out there and you go
is there anything else besides all and
here we go again it just never
inside or that's my theory and rule
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips is connect to the
future how do we brainwash ourselves
in times of stress and anxiety
in order to become more peaceful loving
and successful
in the future how do we brainwash
ourselves in a different way
sure well um
that's what uh i have spent just about
my whole life
and and um
wow i mean
the first and most important thing is
that you have to understand
that if 95 of who you are is a set of
unconscious programs
then the first step is lighting a match
in a dark place if you want to become
someone else you got to become aware of
who you are
yes that means you got to start thinking
about what you've been thinking about
you got to start paying attention to how
you speak got to be conscious you
demystify the word meditation and the
word meditation literally means become
familiar with yeah when you become so
familiar with your thoughts so aware of
your emotions so conscious of your
habits that you wouldn't go unconscious
to them again now you're no longer the
program right so so getting people
disentangled from that program we found
out as a formula and when we teach
people how to do certain things with
their focus
and opening their awareness when we
teach them how to create a very
disorderly brain that has been driven by
the hormones of stress into a more
orderly coherent brain and teach them
how to open their focus and practice
that they'll come up against those
thoughts and they'll become so familiar
with them listen to this they won't
believe him anymore when they come up
any longer wow and so when they hear him
in their day they'll be like that's not
going to stop me from my future
so if they're sitting there and they
want to quit
just because they're sitting still
and they're not quitting
then they're developing a will that's
greater than those programs and you're
breaking out of the shell and you keep
doing that you're going to get up and do
the work every day because you did it
yesterday and you're going to want to do
more of that because you're getting out
of your past and it feels better and if
you keep doing that and you keep feeling
better every day the question is why
wouldn't you do it every day because you
would ultimately just feel better and
then the more whole you feel means the
more you are connected to your future
imagine if you felt every single day
and this is what i do work on
if i could stay connected to the
emotions of my future all day long
there's no way i would be looking for
when it would be happening how could i
look for when it would be happening if i
feel like it's happening i wouldn't look
anymore which means i wouldn't be
separate from it and that's when you
start creating the magic right that's
when you're in that zone and that's when
that reaffirms that personality that
you're becoming and now you don't you
know wake up in the morning oh god i
gotta create my future now you're
you're gonna jump out of bed be excited
you're not gonna want that magic to end
to the materialist
who's waiting for their wealth to show
up to feel abundant they're in their
past
the person who's waiting for the success
to feel empowered is in their past
the person who's waiting for their
healing to feel wholeness
they're in their past
the person who's waiting for their
riches to come to feel gratitude
they're in their past they're
materialists
in other words
you have to feel empowered in order for
your success to show up
you have to feel abundant for your
wealth to find you
you have to be in gratitude for you to
create the life that you want
and by you teaching your body
emotionally what that future could feel
like ahead of the actual experience
is changing your biology
because most people wait for something
outside of them to change how they feel
inside of them a habit is a redundant
set of automatic unconscious thoughts
behaviors and emotions that's acquired
through repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind
so now the person running through the
same routine every single day is on
autopilot and their body's now dragging
them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists
is the sweet spot of the generous
present moment that is when the body and
mind are free from those conditions so
along with those emotions that influence
the same thoughts
people start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled they start
getting more afraid more anxious more
depressed and now the body is literally
being depleted
of energy because it's believing that
it's living in an emergency situation
and in emergency you tap all the body's
resources for some threat whether it's
real or imagined
and so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool
but the arousal that's created from
those stress hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems
and the conditions in their life to
reaffirm their conditioning or their
addiction to that emotion
and in a sense they become addicted to
the life they don't even like and this
is why change is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay i'm not
going to say i can't i'm not going to
judge another person i'm not going to
blame i'm not going to complain i'm not
going to make excuses i'm not going to
be a victim i'm not going to talk trash
about anybody i'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours
and the body's saying you're out of
schedule you normally at eight in the
morning you're getting traffic and
you're angry then at 11 o'clock you
check your emails and you're really
judgmental and frustrated the body's
saying well you've been doing this for
the last 20 years you're just going to
stop today so now the body which has
been conditioned emotionally to be the
mind wants to return back to its
familiar territory to the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on
this is a good time to judge that come
on this is a good time to suffer it's
your ex's fault it's it's your it's the
government's fault it's uh
you know it's the weather what are the
news whatever it is and if we
accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those pharmacy of
chemicals
and so that's when the person makes the
same choice
does the same thing creates the same
experience just for that familiar
feeling okay i'll complain just so i can
feel suffering then
they'd rather
be unhappy
and step into the unknown well look i
mean i think that emotions are energy in
motion
and so let's just say that um
[Music]
we share the same experiences okay i
don't we're friends and we share the
same experience you're from london i've
been to london my daughter lives in
london and we have hey you do this i do
that you did the you know you own this i
own that you know so what we do is we
actually look to see when we meet people
if we're matching neurologically if
we're matching emotionally so if we
share the same experiences we share the
same emotions and if we share the same
emotions we can relate to one another so
this is where it gets sticky so then the
moment you start saying ah
that person did that to you once yeah
that person i had a similar experience
to that person to that to me now
now
we open the door like i'm gonna use you
to reaffirm
my
attachment to that emotion
and let's just work it up so that you
can suffer and i can suffer and then we
can have a conversation and literally
we're sharing the same energy and if
we're sharing the same energy we're
sharing the same information and we're
bound by an invisible field
of energy that keeps us connected yes so
then what does it take to break that
energetic field an energy that's greater
than the energy that's holding it
together that's how you separate atoms
that become a molecule you they're
they're bound by an invisible field of
energy that's keeping them connected so
you got to use a greater energy than the
energy that's holding them together to
separate them well in order for you to
change then you can't have energy
without awareness or consciousness you
got to go to a greater level of
consciousness and change your energy and
nobody changes jay until they change
their energy when they change their
energy they change their life so then
you may say well this person you know i
i use this person and i use my enemy to
reaffirm my addiction to hatred i use my
co-worker to reaffirm my addiction to
judgment i use my ex to reaffirm my
addiction to resentment that we have
these different people in our lives that
we need to remind us of who we think we
are the enemy dies and you find another
one
you know you know your co-worker uh
leaves and you start judging another one
it's just
it's not any it's not that so then
when there's no longer a vibrational
match
when you start doing the work
there's no longer a vibrational match
with you and your past present reality
that that person or that condition any
longer
that person or condition is going to
spiral away because you're no longer
you're no longer in need of that so then
our life begins to change when we change
our energy and we begin to take our
power back that's essential for us to
begin to create with now some people
can't handle that because
they're not conscious that they're doing
it so they'll be working on their vision
of the future
and yet they'll spend two hours
lowering their energy back into
victimization or suffering and they want
to know why their future isn't happening
well
there's an unconscious program let's go
after that and once you start going
after that
now all of a sudden your life starts to
change again so you can't say it doesn't
work on some level we don't work and if
you're really invested in this
the question is what is it about me
where am i directing my attention or my
energy who am i using to reaffirm some
conditioning that i need to remember as
my old self so then when you stop
reacting to the person or the person is
now complaining to you and you're not
complaining back
it's going to be an uncomfortable moment
because
you're all of a sudden seeing a part of
you
you used to be that you no longer are
and you have to be willing
to not go there and over time that
person will thank you and they'll say i
didn't even know that i was complaining
that much and
by changing yourself you help others
self-love is no longer about pleasure or
having a car it's something that you're
cultivating within you so then imagine
we have research to show and this is
such a this is such a
duality
that when you start seeing the brain
start synchronizing getting coherent the
front of the brain on the back of the
brain that two hemispheres coming
together and you we can say to
scientists that come and study our work
oh watch this ed's gonna pop what do you
mean just watch this is gonna be good
and all of a sudden you see this brain
going into this kind of psychic union
the heart blows wide open you see
coherence going on and you look around
at that person and there's tears running
down their face
imagine feeling so whole
that it's impossible to want i mean how
can you want when you're whole because
you feel like you already have it now
when you reach that point
that's when the magic happens because
now you are worthy to receive and the
universe only gives us what we think
we're worthy of receiving share this
with them please yeah i think i know for
me i mean
um
i'm curious and i'm a pragmatist i mean
if you tell me something all i want to
know is how i'm going to use it in my
life yes and i'm not in the dinner
conversation because nobody changes from
that you know i mean i'm a doer and i
want to be around doers and
that's why you and i connect so well i
think and i yeah obviously and and and
and uh
you you create a group of people
that are passionate about transformation
and they've they've done some of the
work when we were doing our four day
four and a half day uh advanced
workshops right around the end of the
event i was seeing people starting to
notice seeing some really great
transformations and i thought this is
the pop yeah as a pop yeah big pops and
we were like we had to send them home
and i was like oh god man if i could
just have them for a week so we created
these week-long events where people
retreat from their lives
and
they remove the constant stimulation in
their external environment that reminds
them of who they think they are as a
personality yes they separate themselves
from the people they know and the places
they go and the things that they do at a
certain amount of time in their routine
mundane life so we'll bridge a little
quantum physics with a little neural
science little neuro
endocrinology a little epigenetics
psychoneuroimmunology those are all
sciences about possibility
and i now know that if you can give
people sound scientific information
and you know
for me that's the language
and then if they can turn to the person
next to them and explain it you're not
going to get off the hook
if you can't explain it it's not wired
in your brain but if you can build a
model and explain it you're installing
the neurological hardware in your brain
in preparation for the experience so the
more you understand what you're doing
and why
how gets easier because you can assign
meaning to it so then if i can set up
the conditions in the environment and
give them the proper instructions and
push the envelope a little bit yeah and
people who get their behaviors to match
their intentions and their actions equal
to their thoughts they get their mind
and body working together they're going
to have a new experience and the
experience then is not only going to
enrich the philosophical circuits in
their brain because experience does that
but it's going to produce an emotion so
they're going to start feeling more
unlimited you got to stay conscious
and not go unconscious and it turns out
that 95 of the time we're unconscious so
if you're going to stay conscious then
there's an element that also requires a
certain amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so
the thoughts that they're thinking
are slipping by their awareness
unnoticed because they're hardwired in
their brain because they've been saying
i can't it's too hard my life will never
change it's someone else's fault those
thoughts have consequences in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious
of those unconscious thoughts becomes
aware of how they speak and how they act
and they notice
how they're feeling they're no longer
the program they're the consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
there are
when you when you're distracted by your
environment and you got your cell phone
and your tweeting and your
instagramming and facebook and whatever
people do you're distracted by that
feeling
but i now know that if you take a person
and you say okay close your eyes
sit in the in the silence of any
external stimulation remove the
environment sit your body down like an
animal body is the animal tell it to
stay i'm gonna feed you
you can check your cell phone you can
shower you can have your coffee but when
i say
and so then here comes the challenge
right so and and then
if you say then you're not going to live
in the familiar future a familiar past
or predictable future you're not going
to think about how long you've been
meditating what you got to do you you
labor
for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it
but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say i
think i'm meditating wrong i always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and
check your cell phone or have a cup of
coffee and you become aware that it's on
autopilot and wants to do that and you
say
come on over here
and you return it back to the present
moment
you're executing a will now
that's greater than the program and if
the person
wants to just get angry while they're
sitting there there's an arousal and
they notice the body is amping up and
revving up and they settle it back down
now they're telling the body it's no
longer the mind
that they're the mind now we've
researched this
and it's tedious
in the beginning at first because david
is fighting goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner or later the body is trained to a
new mind and when that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from body as energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life
and they're
they're working and lowering the volume
of that emotion the more they lower the
volume of that emotion the more they're
going to take their attention off that
person and problem and they're going to
take their power back there's going to
be a break
in their attention from that
circumstance and now they build their
own field and now there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because they've overcome their
old personality self so
i think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming
overcoming
overcoming overcoming until we become
somebody else and when that occurs and
the person starts thinking differently
and they start acting differently
and they start feeling differently
they're a new personality and yeah they
start seeing those synchronicities and
serendipity
how
bad
does it have to get i mean to what
denominator
to what lowest level do you have to
reach
before people really make up their mind
to change my message is why wait i mean
when you're feeling so altered
emotionally you feel so bad that's the
moment you could actually see yourself
for the first time because you're you're
not answering your cell phone you're not
responding to all your texts you're not
watching tv you're not going out to
dinners you're not calling people back
you're something's altered in you and
you're starting to become self-aware
right
so then
people wait to that lowest moment where
they can start to see themselves through
the eyes of somebody else well
if you're waking up every day and you're
combining a clear intention with an
elevated emotion and you're changing
your emotional state to be elevated
you could still see the old self from an
elevated point of view and be state
conscious then from a limited point of
view and that's what i want for people
like let's go i mean what do you got to
lose what people are going to start
wondering like did you change your
medication
what's up with that guy something's
different about him you're not
predictable any longer right then we say
to our our community you know when
you're changing you just stop talking
about it you're just too busy being it
something's happening you know and
that's
the repetition of getting a few days in
a row
of that really well i always say
god if you had a great meditation you
wake up feeling better
at the end of that meditation than when
you started and you do that the next day
and then the next day you're gonna start
feeling better all the time and that
your body's gonna start feeling better
and everything's gonna start feeling
better and you're gonna start feeling
better about life so
you ask the person why are you so
unhappy why are you so frustrated why
are you so resentful the moment you ask
that their brain is going to associate
that emotion to a past event to a memory
into a memory
that's because they have nothing to look
forward to in their future so if you're
not being defined by a vision of the
future it just means to me that you're
more in love with your past
than you are with the future so how do
you teach people to believe in a future
that they can't see or experience with
their senses yet but they've thought
about enough times in their mind that
their brain is literally changed to look
like the event has already occurred the
latest research in neuroscience says
that's absolutely possible we know that
and how do you teach a person
to select a new possibility in their
future and begin to emotionally embrace
that future before it's made manifest to
such a degree that their body is their
unconscious mind is believing it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and they're signaling new
genes and new ways ahead of the
environment
now to their body begins to change to
look like the event has already occurred
we've proven that that's possible now
think about this so the more you think
about your desired future the joy
the gratitude the
uh
the feelings you want to have that are
more positive the more you think about
it as it's as a future thing happening
the more your body shifts now
exactly so your body is believing it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment now think about this the
stronger the emotion you feel from some
condition in your life the more altered
you feel inside of you the more you
narrow your focus on the cause and the
brain freezes an image and takes a
snapshot and that memory now is embossed
in the brain it's branded in there so
then people think neurologically within
the circuits of those past experiences
and they feel chemically within the
boundaries of those emotions and the
stronger the betrayal the stronger the
trauma the more the body's living in the
past right so then so how you reverse
that so now
if you truly got passionate about a
future we've all done this
you get a wild idea in your mind and you
start holding on to that vision and
you're preoccupied with it all of a
sudden the thought in your mind becomes
the experience and you start feeling
the energy of the future now the
stronger the emotion you feel from that
vision the more you're going to pay
attention to the picture in your mind
and now you're remembering your future
and vice versa the stronger you pay
attention to the feeling of the past
pain you're going to create the pain in
this moment exactly so then so it
requires a coherent brain
and we now know that there's a formula
for that and we've got beautiful
research to show that people can do it
they just have to practice and it
requires a coherent heart because
resentment frustration in patience
creates a very incoherent heart yeah and
when that heart becomes incoherent you
stop trusting yourself there's no energy
you get you stop trusting in your future
so then if there's physical evidence in
your brain and body
physical evidence to look like the event
has already occurred it's quite possible
you'll be thinking neurologically within
the circuits of your future and you'll
begin to feel chemically within the
boundaries of that emotion of your
future and how you think and how you
feel as your state of being
and now your state of being is living in
the future instead of the past now
the moment you disconnect from the
emotion of your future because of
traffic or some co-worker or your ex or
whatever people come up with
now you're back to the energy of your
past and now you're going to start
looking for it analyzing why hasn't it
happened well if you're feeling the
emotion of your future why would you
look for it because you would feel like
it already happened and that is the
place where the magic happens so then
you can't just do this get up and then
return back to your old state of being
you got to maintain that modified state
you might even love it
when life happens
let me finish
with a face right now how do you make
well of course of course i mean we all
take blows in our lives yeah and we all
react emotionally but the question is
how long are you going to read right so
then if you can't mediate and regulate
your emotional reactions and those
emotions linger for days that's years
for some people mood and then months
temperament years personality trait so
then the person's personality is
literally based on the past but they
don't know that
because they're doing it over and over
again it becomes a subconscious program
so now
if it requires a coherent brain and a
coherent heart then we have to train
people how to self-regulate what kind of
attention and intention
do you want to place so that that
becomes the loudest voice in your head
and if you keep practicing it the
hardware becomes a software program and
it'll say jay you can do anything jay
you live in no time and accomplish
everything jay
you're unlimited you just got to hang
with it on the other side of this is
greatness whatever you want to program
in there you get the program in there if
you sat down and say how am i going to
be with my wife my husband my partner
how am i going to be with my kids i'm
going to be at work with my co-workers
how am i going to be in traffic
and you close your eyes and you begin to
rehearse in your mind if you're truly
present the brain does not know the
difference between the real life
experience and what you're imagining
so now the brain goes from a record of
the past to a map to the future now
you're installing the hardware keep
practicing it it becomes automatic comes
easier now it's a software program you
may just start behaving differently in
order for you to to really begin to
explore the unknown aspect of yourself
you got to learn how to get beyond the
known aspect of yourself and if you keep
coming back to the known you're going to
miss out on the unknown so you would say
well i don't know anything in the
unknown of course it's the unknown and
if you try to control it there you're
back to the known if you try to predict
it you're back to the known so you got
to go through this trial and error of
just kind of refining your attention
refining your ability and and it's just
got to be something like playing tennis
or playing golf or doing martial arts or
working out or crocheting or stance in
the salsa you just got to keep going man
in the beginning it's tedious and then
when you start finding your groove like
our our community
they don't miss their morning
meditations yeah you know why because
the magic is happening and they know if
they miss it they're gonna they're gonna
cut off from the magic so they whether
they're tired whether they're hungover
whether they're what they're right
they're in right you know and if you if
you wake up in the morning
and you can't get your butt out of bed
you know what that means it just means
you can predict the feeling of
everything that's going to happen in
your life your body's resigned
so then so then you know when you went
on a school trip when you were a kid you
know you woke up before your parents you
knew something new is going to happen
that's the body going wake up wake up
some
so why not
you know put in your put in your time
and then and then measure the effects of
you would cause i mean become a
scientist in your life and really start
to experiment with it okay let me change
my energy let me just write down four
thoughts
that like i can't it's too hard it'll
start tomorrow this doesn't feel right
whatever it is it's be this person's
fault just write those down and say
these thoughts like gandalf on the
bridge yes you may not pass today this
is the end yes so then if you become
conscious of those thoughts now you're
the governor of your thoughts what what
what actions what behaviors do you want
to change do you complain you blame you
judge do you make excuses how do you
talk do you speak limited just pick four
things
that you're not gonna do any longer yeah
what emotions get you in trouble what
are the emotions that you're addicted to
too right that you're addicted to that
keep you returning back to your past if
you don't know
close your eyes for about 30 minutes and
just watch where your mind goes and
watch your feelings and just say okay
it's frustration it's unworthiness it's
self-doubt it's guilt it's frustration
it's shame
just
become conscious of those and just
review them in your mind so that you
don't go unconscious them in your waking
day we have a thousand reasons i have
more than a thousand reasons every day
to be unhappy with managing companies
and staff and people all that but but
then when you rise above that
and you choose just who you want to be
i think it makes a big impression on
your on your family first yourself
and your family and your friends and the
people you work with and then finally
our communities so
i think that people are starting to
figure that out there then and when they
imagine oxytocin levels in our student
body
the love hormone the love chemical 200
times outside of normal the latest
research on oxytocin a slight slight
elevation in oxytocin it's impossible to
hold a grudge now so then what that
means is you feel
so amazing
that why would you want to
hold a grudge against that person so
forgiveness then is not something that
you have to try to do to be spiritual
it's the side effect of saying
i don't want to give up this feeling for
you or anybody so i'm letting it go i'm
freeing you i'm free in myself and my
goodness there's more liberation of
energy i call that the natural state of
being and we're knocking on that door
why
because as you begin to open your heart
to life again and you start trusting in
your future and trusting in yourself a
little bit more and you start
self-regulating with your heart you do
that properly and you lead from that
place from that level of awareness your
life will change
in dramatic ways and why is that
essential because when people start
doing that effectively
oxytocin signals nitric oxide nitric
oxide signals a chemical called
endothelial derived relaxing factor and
that causes the arteries in your heart
and lungs jay to literally swell just
like when you're
when your sexual organs are aroused and
blood flow moves into them male and
female that's a different consciousness
there's a different energy in there
imagine the same intensity moving into
your heart
that's what people are experiencing that
is a level of love
that's not like a love for your puppy
it's not like the love for your partner
this is transcendent of that this is the
most familiar unfamiliar feeling you
will ever have it'll be distant and at
the same time very close and you'll
start to see the hidden meaning behind
all things and now
when you walk
in the presence of your greatest
betrayer
the person who threw you under the bus
whatever it is
when you walk in from this place
there will be no emotional reaction you
will just see that person for who they
are who you used to be now compassion
then is no longer something that you
have to try to do
it's the end product of doing the work
and i think that
mystics and saints and
masters of old understood this
so when they thought of that person
they didn't allow that thought to
produce a feeling or an energy that
would lower their energy
they understood that when they had the
thought of that person they saw their
limitation it wasn't hurting them it was
only hurting themselves now
i think that if the world was doing that
wow we'd have a very different world
thoughts uh to me produce an electrical
charge in the quantum field
and feelings produce a magnetic charge
in the quantum field thoughts wait
thoughts produce a what an electrical
charge okay and feelings produce a
magnetic charge and how you think and
how you feel
broadcast an electromagnetic signature
that influences every single atom in
your life the thought sends the signal
out now think about this and the feeling
draws the event back so you could have
the intent that you want wealth you want
health you want success that's your
intent that's your thought but if you're
waiting for the experience to happen to
feel it then you're not
drawing the experience to you because
you're not feeling the emotion right so
then
teaching people once again how to
balance their thoughts and feelings
because you can you can enter that cycle
either place sometimes we do a
meditation
we start opening our heart we start
elevating the body's energy and then
those emotions can drive certain
thoughts of your future other times you
open your awareness you create brain
coherence you have the vision of your
future you begin to emotionally
experience it
however you want to jump on that cycle
and then sustain it because the longer
you're conscious of that energy
the more you're drawing your future to
you so then most people spend their
lives right
they we live in this realm called
space-time three-dimensional reality and
you move your body through space in
three-dimensional reality it takes time
yeah so everything all your goals all
your dreams all your visions you're
gonna have to get your body up and drag
it through space every day to pay off
that you know that home that's in your
future right right
when you create from the field instead
of from matter
when you use a vibrational match between
your energy and some potential and your
thoughts and feelings are coherent now
you are going to begin to collapse time
and space where the experience is going
to be drawn to you now now you're the
vortex to your destiny and now you don't
have to go anywhere to get it because
you're not playing by the rules of
three-dimensional reality you're playing
by the rules of energy and the quantum
if the word meditation means become
familiar with right
then you know people say oh well you
shouldn't focus on the negative well
really that's 95
of who you are and you got to begin to
dismantle or denature that old
personality and that means you're going
to have to come up against the cravings
that the body has emotionally you know
like it is it's eight o'clock in the
morning and you're doing your meditation
you're normally in traffic and you want
to get angry and your body's going hey
you're off schedule so let me just find
something that's mapped in the brain
that i i'll bring up a past experience
why you can feel a little anger well
once you become aware of that
now
now the game is on right because now
you're working to become conscious of
that and not go unconscious again and it
takes an incredible amount of awareness
yes it takes a great amount of
consciousness and you can't have
consciousness without energy so you
gotta raise your energy in order to get
to otherwise you're gonna be consumed
yes you're gonna return back right so
gosh so if you start becoming familiar
so conscious of those unconscious
thoughts they would never slip by your
mind unchecked by you now
that is when you really catch yourself
right and the research shows that you
can get better at this you could
actually sense the thought before it
comes
so then you start firing and wiring new
thoughts you start thinking to yourself
who am i going to be when i open my eyes
well how am i going to how am i going to
make a difference in the world today who
am i going to be
how am i going to love how am i going to
give how am i going to serve how am i
going to contribute what what things do
i want to really do today and the in the
act of closing your eyes and just
thinking about and rehearsing what
you're going to do
your brain doesn't know the difference
and if you get caught up in it
you begin to install the neurological
hardware in your brain to look like
you've already done it
now the brain's no longer a record of
the past now it's a map to the future
you are priming your brain and if you
keep doing it yes the hardware will
become a software program you know what
that means you just might start acting
like a happy person well there's no
surprise there you install the circuits
stress hormones arouse the body so you
have your attention on your body stress
hormones alert the brain so you're aware
of everything in your environment like
an octopus with tentacles in all
different directions you gotta control
and predict everything in your life
and if you're living by the hormones of
stress you're always investing your
attention and energy into the known
future based on the past so you're on a
you're on a you're in a line of time
here in a timeline so then let's think
about it
how you gonna make thought more real
than anything else are you gonna create
from thought well let's close our eyes
let's disconnect from the environment
right less sensory information coming
into the brain less distraction as you
said let's play some soft music in the
background let's stick some ear plugs in
our whatever you want to do diminish
sensory but now you're sitting down
you're not eating
you're not tasting you're not smelling
you're not feeling
so there's more less less sensory input
coming into your body so then now your
brain waves begin to change they start
slowing down and you move from this beta
brainwave pattern where
you're aware that you have a body in
space and time or your attention is on
the outer world or your senses are
giving you information less sensory
information now your inner world starts
becoming more real than the outer world
and you're not the voice in your head
that's always talking to you as your
brain waves change you start seeing
images and pictures and symbols and less
in that vocalization that
subvocalization so your brainwaves start
changing the alpha you're going to start
creating start dreaming pretending right
so then
if you say to your body
you're going to sit down for an hour
and i know you're on a program because
you wake up every morning and do the
exact same thing and now i'm going to
make you sit just like said to an animal
you sit
you stay and your body's going to say
i'm going to die my bladder is going to
explode i need a coffee i got a lot of
emails to do that's the program
and you say to your body
today we do battle today this is it and
you sit through that and you make your
way even though your body's trying to
get up and you keep settling it back
down
i'm telling you when you start your day
that day you will be more kind
more loving less judgmental more patient
more present because you're mastering
the present moment that means you're not
in the predictable future you're not in
the familiar past you're mastering time
and so then if where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
and all of your attention is in the
present moment
you've got a lot of energy to do amazing
things and you know when someone's
present with you in your life because
they're paying attention to you yeah and
you know when they're not present
because they're not paying attention to
yourself so the act of getting more
present means you're putting a lot of
energy in the present moment and you're
taking your power back from all these
things and people in your life so
we teach people this
as they start breaking through and they
start being able to unfold into this
field as an awareness
and they're not putting their attention
on their boss or their ex or their wife
or their kids or their cell phone or
their whatsapp or their facebook
they're they're they're not thinking at
all
so then as they're sensing the space
they can't think and if you can't think
you can't analyze and if you can't
analyze the analytical mind is what
separates the conscious mind from the
subconscious you just open the door wow
and so now you can reprogram it if you
could give everyone in the world an
experiment to do for 30 days or one
activity that they'd have to do every
day for 30 days what would it be oh i
would ask them to take out a piece of
paper and write down every thought
that they've been thinking that's
standing in the way between their future
and and where they are
to write down every habit or behavior
even how they speak
that stops them from becoming the person
that is healthy wealthy or free and then
to begin to
uh
recognize the emotions
that keep them in the same state of
being every single day and become so
conscious of those thoughts behaviors
and emotions that they wouldn't let any
of them slip by unnoticed by them then i
would have them write down the thoughts
they do on a fire and wire in their
brain i would have them write down what
the behaviors look like of a great
person that they wanted to become
and i would have them practice thinking
about it and practice rehearsing it and
then i would say to them
what emotions would you feel when your
future happened because you have to
teach your body emotionally what that
future feels like before it happens and
every day if you practice that
diligently and sincerely and just become
conscious of who you no longer want to
be and keep becoming conscious of who
you do want to be
you should begin to see evidence in your
life and when it comes in a way that you
least expect
that surprises you and leaves no doubt
that it's come from a greater mind then
you'll be inspired to do it again and
now we believe we're more of the
creators of our lives if you said well
listen i'm not going to wait for my
healing
to feel gratitude i'm not going to wait
for my new relationship to feel love
i'm going to actually teach my body
emotionally
what that future feels like before it
happens now
this is a big turnaround for a lot of
people because we're so reliant on the
outer world to change our inner world
right waiting and
waiting is not creating i mean period
and when people are they could have the
greatest intentions in the world
but if they don't combine that with an
elevated emotion there's no signal
because the elevated emotion is the
carrier it's the energy that carries the
thought
so then
when we're in separation in lack waiting
for our wealth to feel abundance we're
basically living our whole life in pain
right
so then if you reason this and a person
can get up from their meditation and
they literally feel differently
and they're feeling the emotions of
their future before it happens this is
turning
the whole process around
they can't be looking for
why would they be looking for it if they
felt like it there it already happened
now there's no separation now this is
when those serendipities and
coincidences and opportunities begin to
show up in people's lives so it's work
but then when they start seeing the
experience in their life
all of a sudden they
start believing they're more of the
creator of their life yeah and less of
the victim of their life a community of
like-minded like like
similar energy of people
uh everybody understands they get one
another you know you you communities
tends to be the thing now that in terms
of our
social media and the feedback we're
getting
everybody wants more community because
you get a you get a thousand people an
audience and their energy is
synchronized now you're looking at
something so much bigger we're just
going to measure this i just talked to a
researcher yesterday
we're going to measure a thousand people
when they reach that synchronized moment
when they're we can we know that the
entire
social coherence in the room is orderly
then if you're producing a ambient
coherent magnetic field in your heart
and
you're tuning into a thought or an
intent and you've got a thousand people
doing that and your energy is going to
start interfering and co-mingling with
the persons next to you when that energy
starts to synchronize
it's going to produce a bigger wave the
higher the amplitude the higher the wave
the more energy there is so now you have
one mind and one heart and now when it
comes to healing others and we've done
the research on this now and we're
collecting the data that we're teaching
people how to administer
a change in energy in the person that's
laying there because it's not matter
that emits a field that's the wrong way
to think about it it's the field that
creates matter
you change the field you change matter
you're not it's not your job to change
the tumor the tumor is the illusion it's
the pattern in the field
that's that that has to be changed so
once people start reversing this then
you start seeing the tumors disappearing
you start seeing blind people seeing
deaf people hearing you start seeing
people with parkinson's disease switch
on i mean you start seeing
stage four cancers reversing because now
they're you're you're you're swimming
upstream you're going to the headwaters
and making that change it's so important
then that of the infinite places you can
put your attention
let's put it on your heart
now where you place your attention is
where you place your energy why because
we want this center to bloom
1400
hundred different chemicals that we
storm regenerate the body let's breathe
let's open this up let's practice this
let's start learning how to lead with a
heart a different consciousness yeah in
the beginning
it's a little difficult but
you stay with it and you practice it
pedal by pedal by pedal placing your
attention there you're putting your own
life force
back into your heart you're turning your
love inward and the body will start
responding and in a week's time if we're
doing that three times a day or over and
over again
sooner or later that thing is going to
start blooming and just like when your
sexual organs are aroused and they're
engorged with blood
this center
when you start feeling love you make a
chemical called oxytocin
oxytocin signals nitric oxide
nitric oxide
signals a chemical called derived
endothelial relaxing factor you know
what that is
it causes the arteries in your heart to
literally open up so your heart is going
to be filled with blood and oxygen and
nutrients it's physiological it's going
to feel full
you're going to have a heart on in a
sense your heart is going to fail right
and when that happens
you experience a level of love
that passes all understanding you your
cup runneth over i mean it is
and people are in they're sobbing
because
they realize that this this center
finally like a child i think we're all
faced with great opportunities
brilliantly disguised as impossible
situations
and in order like for me personally and
i and after looking through your book
and reading a good portion of it
i mean for me there's there's no school
of ancient wisdom that you need to go to
to be initiated your life is your
initiation if you're paying attention so
we meet challenges in our life from a
certain level of mind right a certain
level of consciousness or
unconsciousness and even einstein said
we have to go to a greater level of
consciousness
than the consciousness that's created
the problem well what is consciousness
consciousness is awareness
and awareness means possibilities that
you haven't thought of before
so
we confront problems or challenges in
our life and as a side note
i was having breakfast with a researcher
just last week who's studying what
happens when we perceive a condition in
our environment as a problem how it
weakens the organism they're measuring
this and when a person sees it as a
challenge how they draw energy they
raise the energy of their body back into
order
so
if we said i want to be
wealthy or i want to be healthy
well what you want to be that because
you're not it
so the initiation of going from not it
here to it here you're gonna have to
climb some steps and there's going to be
some blind spots so you try it out and
it doesn't work
well that's because there's a part of
you that's still in a habit there's part
of you that's still unconscious okay so
what is it about myself and that
circumstance
that i am feeling
about that circumstance and that feeling
is causing me to think about it so you
say oh it's impossible they'll never
change i'll hire a hitman i'll hire the
mafia i'll hire an attorney i'll have my
friend's friend to talk to him and
nothing changes right well
you're not you're not separate
from that experience you're involved in
it and how you think and how you feel
broadcast energy into the field so your
energy is the same every day and as long
as your energy is the same nothing's
going to change in your life either and
nobody changes until they change their
energy so then
what piece of knowledge
what piece of information what would
love do what would greatness look like
okay i don't know all right well
certainly somebody in history has faced
this problem
don't get on facebook and say does
anybody have any answers don't get
go look it up and study and read and
learn you'll own it and you'll say wow
that person that was wealthy
they failed 500 times
well hell i had the wrong view of wealth
okay then failure is not a thing i got
to overcome failure well yep just climb
the step yeah okay i'm reacting to that
circumstance with the same emotion that
emotion is firing the same thoughts i'm
broadcasting the same energy into the
field
if i were facing that circumstance and
situation again with that person that
circumstance what do i learn from that
circumstance how could i do it
differently the next time
find out a solution and rehearse it
install a circuitry so when you get in
the circumstance you're not going to
respond in an automatic habituation yeah
now you're at a greater level of
consciousness now you're looking at
possibilities that you weren't looking
at before because you were unconscious
now
that process of trial and error is so
important in the spiritual path
how many times
do we have to forget before we remember
and then we remember and we forget again
and it takes constantly remembering
until we stop forgetting and when we get
to that point now we're conscious
now there's wisdom and wisdom is the
memory
of the experience without the emotional
charge now you're ready for the new
adventure so then
people draw conclusions and say oh it's
that person that ripped me off as that
person
that what now now you don't create your
reality you only create reality when
things are good
well somehow you got to tango through
this somehow your objectivity in not
reacting emotionally
is going to change the energy of how you
address this situation consciousness is
awareness awareness is paying attention
and noticing and so 95
of who we are by the time we're 35 years
old is a set of unconscious automatic
programs that we've just practiced so
many times that we're not consciously
thinking about those so in order for you
to change to answer the initial question
that you asked
the first step is you got to become
conscious of your unconscious thoughts
and you gotta you gotta start looking at
those hardwired thoughts that that you
think every day that are just circuits
that have been fired and wired together
how do we do that should we write a list
at the end of the day or one of the most
common thoughts we had that day like how
does someone become aware you don't have
to do that you just have to sit down
close your eyes and not move and then
you'll get you'll you'll start seeing
what am i thinking about right now yeah
and all you want to do is observe the
thought because
when you begin to observe that thought
you're no longer the program now you're
the consciousness observing the program
and you're starting to pull out of the
program thinking about the thinking yeah
who's doing the thinking of the thinking
about the thinking that's who you are
when you're not the program that's
awareness right you got to become aware
of how you speak how you act become so
conscious
so aware of it that you won't go
unconscious and let that thought or that
behavior run you you got to say oh my
god
this feeling that i've been living by
for the last 20 years is actually guilt
i didn't know it was guilt because it
just feels like me
and all of a sudden as you start
becoming conscious of it you're
beginning to objectify your subjective
self you're you're pulling out of those
programs and nobody likes to do that
because it's uncomfortable they'd rather
turn on their cell phone start texting
get on the internet
you know watch tv to distract them from
that moment and that is what they have
to move through in order to get to their
to their own personal freedom so the
first step is becoming conscious and
meditation means to become familiar with
to become conscious of to to become so
conscious
of your unconscious self that you won't
go unconscious to any thought any
behavior or emotion and get ready
because it takes a tremendous amount of
energy
to do that and awareness
to stay conscious and so
we fall from grace yeah fine you gotta
you got you're awake you got another day
let's go again how often do you fall oh
my gosh i mean
how many times have i done it thousands
but i'm not going to give up because
the moments
in which i do connect or the moments
that i do have that transcendental
experience
what matters the most after it when i
have that transcendental moment i look
back
at all of those difficult meditations
those difficult days and those are the
ones you remember you don't remember the
good meditations you remember the ones
where you came up against yourself and
you went a little further and you said
i'm gonna go a little further and go
further
or
you had a rough day and you just went in
and you just you at the end of the day
you surrender and you have the classic
oh my god moment
there's no linear correlation it's just
whether you're willing to live in
creation instead of living in survival
and so
you get better at it you know we just
get better at it and for me um staying
conscious and staying aware and staying
present
is an art because
you you know when someone's present with
you in your life because they're paying
attention to you
you know when they're not present with
you because they're not paying attention
to you so imagine this field of
information this
this this intelligence that lives within
you and i that's governing everything
material in this world it's a
self-organizing intelligence
you have access to it so you better get
present with it
as well as you can get present with
anything else and just because you can't
see it
doesn't mean it doesn't exist
that that realm you can't experience
with your senses you could only
experience with your awareness
so then
people have to take their attention off
their bodies and go from a somebody to a
nobody
take their attention off the people in
their life and go from that they
identify with and go from a someone to a
no one take their attention off the
things in their life their cell phone
their computer their car and go from
something to nothing take their
attention off where they sleep where
they work where they're sitting and go
from somewhere to nowhere take their
attention off the predictable future in
the familiar past and time and go from
some time to no time and now if you're
taking all of your attention off of
everything material in this
three-dimensional reality now there's
only one other thing that's left that
means you're an awareness your
consciousness and now that is the bridge
that is the door to the quantum field
and you can't enter the quantum field as
a somebody so
if someone has spent their whole life
working on having the perfect body or so
much so they have so much attention on
their pain
where you place your attention is where
you place your energy it's going to take
some work for them to take all of their
attention off their body right because
they'll go they'll do it and then
they'll go back let's see if the pain's
still there all the pain's still there
so
it's a little bit of a waltz in the
beginning but as people start applying
this
you start getting better at it let's
demystify meditation because it has so
many stigmas around it close your eyes
retreat from your life
disconnect from your body disconnect
from your environment disconnect from
your schedule and just give yourself an
hour or 45 minutes or 20 minutes because
when you invest in yourself you invest
in your future and when you believe in
yourself
you believe in possibilities and when
you believe in possibilities you believe
in yourself and if you don't believe in
possibilities then you don't believe in
yourself and you don't believe in
yourself you don't believe in
possibilities so then but if you have a
community a living organism yeah where
it's becoming the new normal yes and you
want to join that living organism and
you want to you want to be a part of
that and and every every stride you make
feeds the living organism every stride
every effort you make
to connect is is amazing because
that which we are seeking is seeking us
it's not like
it is it matches our efforts and so then
when when people have that
uncompromising will
the same way that they go shopping for a
dress or a pair of earrings or go to the
gym and work out with the same intensity
with the same passion
come up against themselves and just say
when the body's going given everything
it has it's when you say that's all you
got that's it that's all you're going to
put out to work i'm ready yeah and so
then
when you start overcoming that
the side effect of it is that all of a
sudden you're happy for no reason
and you're less seduced in believing
that something else you need something
outside of it outside of you to make you
feel better all of a sudden you're
feeling better every day without
anything outside of you
and now all of a sudden you start
showing up unpredictable in your life
they're saying that ed guy he's
different he's on a different medication
but in actuality you're just freer right
and so so then as we begin to remove
these layers that stop the flow of the
divine in us that had an essence in us
the side effect is we become more
willful we become more mindful become
more conscious we become more loving
it's it's it's nature you know it's just
it just becomes becomes who we are at
the end of the day if you really wanted
to be wealthy say
how did i do today did i make the right
choices was i ethical was i purpose
driven was i was i was am i interested
in making a difference was i fair was i
tempered
did i really think before i spoke what
what did i remember reading about that
book about that person that did it how'd
i do
and if you said i when did i fall from
grace when did i lose it okay
i want that opportunity again
i want another shot at that and i'm
going in this way what would love do in
this situation what would greatness do
and now you you evolve your experience
and somehow there's a door there's an
opening something shifts something's
changing and now here we go we climb
another ladder and then all of a sudden
there's another challenge and then
people who finally arrive at their
abundance they could care less if
they're abundant they're already knowing
that they've earned the right for it so
so there's sometimes a shortcut in the
process
if we're if we really learn and we
really get it
but the trial and error is so
important because
not only is the person earning the right
to be wealthy
but they're earning the right to live in
worthiness worthy to receive like hey
you people people come to our work all
the time for a lot of reasons and one of
the common reasons is they want to get
healthy yeah and in their own because
they're dealing with a very serious
health condition and i always say the
same thing to them
stop wanting to be healthy learn the
formula yeah on how to get healthy learn
the formula on how to heal and the
healing will be the side effect of it if
you're obsessing about why am i not
healed you're still the old person
you're gonna become that person every
day right yeah it turns out that when
you sit down
and the people that we interview that
have had significant changes
when it's no longer about their health
but they are
they are out of the bleachers and
they're on the playing field
and they are coming up against the
belief like one lady said god i i always
thought that
this work really worked this these
concepts are the truth but i never
believed it worked for me
and i was in a car accident in a
wheelchair and then she made the
decision that she was going to overcome
that belief now it was no longer about
her healing it was about overcoming the
belief but she overcame the belief and
showed up every day for herself when you
believe in yourself you believe in
possibilities when you believe in
possibilities you got to believe in
yourself you don't show up for yourself
you don't believe in it yeah and that's
why people don't do the work i mean if
you you believe that your thoughts
created reality
you would show up every day and create
and so a lot of people believe in their
past more than they believe in their
future a lot of people fall in love or
more in love with their past or romance
their past instead of romance their
future or love their future it's it's
that simple so
the initiation process of life
is always going to be there you're
always going to be challenged if if you
want to be a master well then you better
learn how to heal someone else and
you're going to fail a lot of times and
if you think that you're a failure then
you'll quit but if you feel like you
just didn't quite ding it yet and you
show up again
to just ding it and you keep evolving
your experience and go deeper how much
more can i open my heart how much more
can i surrender into this infinite field
how much more can i become can i walk is
it with my eyes open people
do meditations and they have great
meditations me included
and then you get up you open your eyes
and you're back in the program and
people want to know why they haven't
healed them we have testimonies of
people
they're speaking the truth they said my
ms
my rheumatoid and my lupus never went
away
i had great meditations i felt better
then i realized with my eyes open i was
still that person
and now
next level they're in the game of
catching themselves or catching how they
speak they're watching how they think
they're not letting their body fall in
the same emotional state to put them in
the same past experience that the body's
believing it now this is the this is the
great part and when the person finally
breaks through from the chains
and there's a different consciousness of
freedom that happens
they look back at their past
they want to change one thing in their
past because it brought them to that
present moment that's the path no longer
existing that's the freedom so is it
worth the effort yeah it's no longer
about healing it's no longer about
abundance it's about who you're becoming
i will never work in a relationship i
just won't if i'm working in a
relationship something's wrong i'll work
on me
i'll bring my best you bring your best
and we get together and we celebrate it
should work it should work and if it
doesn't then i'm going to step back and
see what is it about me not you what is
it about me that i need to really look
at and change now
if there's a vibrational match and it
flows and it's fun and you connect on
physically mentally mind body soul you
know that's cool i i think that's
healthy
uh
uh but a permission driven person can't
be in a relationship
where you have to keep going back
and and and trying to fix something i
just i just won't do that i just think
that when it when it's right it's right
and i'll know
yeah yeah so i think that i do think
that uh
relationships uh can be easy
and i i do think i i and i think that
they should be
and i and i think that if you're
heart-centered
uh that's a different place you meet
yeah uh than than uh other emotions and
and and i and again every time i have a
mystical moment
and i feel that
transcendental love that i don't even
know the word for
uh every time i have one of those
moments i think i got this all wrong
it's just that it it's it is not
chemical it's electric and you got what
all wrong
well the way we view the world the way
we present we don't see things how they
are we see things how we are you know in
every inner experience that's
transcendental experience enriches
circuitry in your brain experience
produces
emotion or energy in the body so you
start having transcendental moments
where you start connecting to that field
it's signature it's love i mean but not
love like a love for your puppy
this is like this is like an arousal
this is i don't know the other word but
spiritual arousal yeah and we have we
have the evidence we can say
oh watch this watch this person's brain
and scientists are studying our work
i'll say oh
watch she's going to pop in a few
minutes what do you mean just watch
she's going to pop and all of a sudden
this person goes into an arousal the
sympathetic nervous system is so
switched on but the arousal isn't like
an arousal that from the environment
that produces anger or aggression or
fear anxiety or pain or suffering that's
survival in the environment that
produces the arousal this arousal is
coming from energy in the body that's
moving up into the brain and
the arousal is bliss arousal is ecstasy
the arousal is freedom
but it's it's it's not chemical it's
it's you'll feel it in every single cell
in your body now here's the outcome of
that
the outcome of that is that when you
open your eyes and some conditioning
some layer has been removed
your spectrum of the way the world looks
broadens now because now you're wired to
perceive what's always existed
but you didn't have the circuits in
place to perceive them so then it's the
inner experience that literally trans
transforms our experience of the outer
world and so
when you start having moments where you
hit that kind of frequency or you have
those moments of love
you're less dependent on anyone to bring
you happiness
you're you're okay you can love the
person for the flaws
because you can see a part of yourself
you used to be that you no longer aren't
instead of judgment you have compassion
and you can encourage and
and communicate from from a level of
connection instead of intimidation or or
competition or however relationships
work what are the three things we should
say when we wake up in the morning or
think
well first i would say
what is the greatest ideal of myself
that i can be today
and i would not get up until i felt like
that person
the second thing i would say is can i
begin to keep my energy up the entire
day and if i do it properly then i will
be open to opportunities and
possibilities that weren't there before
the last thing i would say is could i
sustain brain and heart coherence to the
point where that intelligence within me
that's giving me life begins to find a
door to open out so i can begin to see
evidence in my world what would you say
every evening before you go to sleep oh
yeah how did i do that
how did i do how did i do how'd i do
today i mean one day one lifetime how
did i do today did i change or help
another human being did i really change
someone's future future timeline lastly
what is the greatest thing i learned so
i have three kids and i've raised my
kids with these principles and and i
think
there are critical periods ed
where
certain information
is more understood
in certain periods where
uh you can you can really advance
uh a teaching or an understanding but
the children you know their first six
years of their life they're very
suggestible to information and their
brain waves are just in a slower pattern
so they don't have any critical
facilities or analytical facilities so
big boys don't cry little girls should
be seen and not heard money is the root
of all evil god is mad at you you're
going to go to hell so kids just take
that all in without any filter and that
becomes the foundation of their
personality and our identity
then you throw in parents
that are 95 percent of the time running
unconscious programs well children have
mirror neurons and mirror neurons
emulate behavior so when you were
feeding your kids when they were young
you took that spoon and you went like
this
you didn't know you were doing that but
you were doing that and they were
watching you and you were watching them
and they were they were turning on the
same circuits in their brain that you
were turning on
just so they could model the behavior so
so then you can't say the kid stop being
an emotional basket pace because you're
not listening to anything you're saying
they're they're observing behavior so
when a lioness takes her cubs out to
hunt they sit and they watch her
and they're when they're watching her
she's priming their brain they're
actually going to emulate her behavior
so as they start observing her
they start turning on the same circuits
they will when they hunt so they start
imprinting it right
so then
with children then
i call it the fast path to enlightenment
because if you want to raise a great kid
you got to be the example
and so
um
you know there's certain principles with
children uh in certain critical periods
you don't tell your kids when they're
four years old you create your reality
fix this you know it's not they're not
ready for that but there are certain
things at certain periods of time that
are really healthy and teaching children
had a short and refractory period of
their emotional reactions is so
important and simple things like a
trampoline
is a great way when a kid is upset
just change their states go yeah let's
go okay and they jump and you jump with
them 10 minutes later
it's gone isn't that true and so then
you're teaching them that kind of
emotional
intelligence parents need to know
that it's so important to understand to
never
rationalize with your kid when they're
emotional
why because do you want to hear anything
when you're emotional you want to be
left alone because no new information
can enter their nervous system that is
not equal to the emotion that they're
experiencing it's not relevant
so then
getting them past their
emotional state and teaching them how to
shorten their refractory period and then
timing
okay when they start getting ready for
bed and it's getting loving and it's
getting quiet and they're settling down
you get in bed with them and you lay
there and you say
you know i had a tough day today
i've been working on my frustration you
know and i didn't do very well today i
just i got angry at a few points i got
frustrated i stayed that way for like
three hours
and you just open the door for kids and
they'll say yeah you know i was playing
the day
no though automatically said and i got
so frustrated with my friend paris you
know
and i'll say well that's all right you
know that's normal we all do that but
what i care about the most
is that if you had another opportunity
tomorrow in the same situation
how would you do it better
and then they'll say well i would do
this and then say really if you do that
this is probably going to happen so
let's work on this together so you start
building a model
and you help them because they're so
neuroplastic
and then once you get that model in
place then you say to them
tell me how to do it again what would
you do now what are they doing
they're rehearsing
and so now they're installing the
circuitry and then you say wait one more
time one more time because you forgot
that one part and you'd be surprised
because they're in that right
suggestible state and then you get the
model down and then you say okay i'm
going to tell you a story
there was these two kids a boy and a
girl this is a boy and a girl right
and they live in this magic land and if
they're young there's castles and
and there's dragons and this little girl
had a best friend you know and you tell
the whole story she was making this
reaction the same time in the same way
and all of a sudden you know she just
decided to do something differently and
then you repeat it
and then you say we know what happened
she wound up being happier and more
loving to herself and more loving with
everybody else
and you know your kids will go
was that me and you say i don't know
so then you're planting the seed
[Music]
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there